hey bonus microbiota and welcome to the
odor foes market analysis for Tuesday
August 15 2017 I apologize it's been a
while since I've done one of these since
last week actually the last Tuesday but
I've just been out cold I've had this
terrible stomach virus I don't know what
you want to call it but it just really
knocked me off for several days
literally I felt like I was dying I was
bedridden even now I still got so sweat
and I still got a fever
but at least my stomach doesn't feel
like I've been in a boxing match and my
throat isn't killing me that much but so
again you know if I haven't gotten to
some of your people's emails bear with
me
you know I said I've really been out you
know then now as I've been out but you
know a lot of my rest of my family has
also gotten this infection so it's sort
of run in its course through our
household so I've been really having to
run around do everything take kids to
the doctor's and Hindoo all sorts of
stuff over blood tests but hopefully you
know things are coming back down to
normal and okay I want to say this up
front no I don't offer a free trial on
the Delta scalper it's only $250 it's
not an arm and a leg so you know I'll
see if you can't afford $250 then you
know you should reconsider should you be
trading or not you know it's I'm not
charging thousands of thousand dollars
for the Delta scalper so if you're
emailing me asking for free trial and I
don't reply it because I don't offer one
okay and I'm not going I don't have the
time to sit there and reply but I see
people putting comments in these videos
oh you know you don't have a free trial
so it's useless looking come on you know
this is not an object designed for
people into shiny object syndrome right
it's designed for people that understand
order flow I want to use order flow in
their trading not people I just want to
go hey this looks interesting I want to
try it no you know really the best the
people that get the most out of this
indicator right I don't say the best
users but people that really get the
most out of it understand
order flow on a basic level and you know
want to add it to their trading arsenal
rather than just want to buy a new
indicator because it looks like hey this
this this looks like you know it's
picking nice turns yes it does pick nice
turns but you know when you add it
together with with order flow
you know it's going to find you really
nice trades like for example this trade
here even though you know we did make a
new low by a tick you know you got a
nice rally here there's other things in
the order flow to help confirm it but
anyway before I jump in let me go
through a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trading contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor and
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost not
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
again the tools used in this
presentation are the order flows trader
which is the volume footprint chart and
the Delta scalper now you know I also
you know I've been down I've been laying
in bed I've been doing a lot of surfing
around on the Internet as you know
there's a lot of volume footprint charts
out there and you know several years ago
there was maybe five six now there's
easily easily double that that's
available for a ninja trader so you know
you've got to make a decision you know
which which software do you want to use
you know which one do you think can help
your trading and you know do the people
that provide it also provide additional
trainings basically I would say support
because you know the data is the same
but you know teach you what to look for
I mean you could have the greatest
volume footprint software out there but
if you don't know what you're looking
for it's kind of pointless right you
know it's it doesn't make sense to have
have the software but not know how to
get the maximum out of it so anyway you
know let's start here with the the first
chart I was showing you was was the
bonds and you know that was this morning
here in the bonds here and you know just
this classic you know it's a classic
divergence and a ratio ratio the next
bar ratio the next bar you know this is
the classic buying signal right here
okay yeah earlier you did have the
Dolphin scalper giving you a buy right
here yeah that's fine but also you know
so you don't have that so you just
looking at a footprint chart this is it
right here you're getting it you know
and this is a beautiful move from 28 all
the way up to 12 before just so
sideways on you for the next you know
hour-and-a-half
we did eventually make you know another
stab at another rally here but it wasn't
lection here to tell you to get short
but this was this was the say the trade
of the day but this is the one I was I
was talking about in the room all
morning I said no this is it
there you go get ready you know maybe I
wasn't convinced here honestly at this
point but you know this next bar gave me
the confirmation so you know what maybe
you miss your entry here at 28 and you
get in in this bar here at 31 okay
that's fine
you still got there's still a lot of
potential there for you okay the ten
range chart here now this is interesting
or am i ears we came down into this low
again you got ratio and divergence right
here on the low of the day this is at
9:38
next bar you got to Delta scalper and
what happens is the market just goes
sideways on you
man sometimes they work out beautifully
more like in the bonds you know
sometimes this just happens on you now
you know I'm corrected it's it's it's
been a crazy last few days you know
going back to last Thursday with North
Korea you know it's like we're being
going to the brink of launching
thermonuclear war and then it's backed
off so you know things in
Charlottesville yeah it's not nice it's
bad you know but you know that that's
not having the effect on the market you
know what's happened it's happening on
the market was all was all due to North
Korea but you know things have toned
down and the markets sort of found you
know a resting a resting point here
you know we literally just you know
spend the rest of the day most of the
day here around the 63 area you know and
even an evening session that's where
we're trading right now okay so I'll
take a look at the four range emini that
is very interesting again yeah this is
one on something I was talking about in
the room today so we're coming down into
this low this is around 848 this morning
when you get a stack selling imbalance
okay and it's just right above the low
okay now yeah I know you see hey I got
stacks
balances get short well I prefer stacks
on imbalances right if they're coming in
near low I prefer them on the other side
of the low going into new lows not going
into the low right like this one is if
this red line is below is said if you
were to get it as you're breaking
through the low I would like it better
why because you know what you're getting
is you know people coming in here
thinking hey we're going to come out
we're going to bust through this low
okay and you know I honestly I used to
think that too you know I used to be a
breakout trader back in the early days
back in the 90s you know those back in
the early days it totally cradle the
range extension breakouts I used to love
them and other thing that that's was
that was my bread and butter
and but then you know you'd run into
problems like this you come into the low
people are coming in and think we're
breaking out what happens it stops right
here right on the low
you got to bounce up okay so if you're
getting short here at the low 62 and a
half you're not going to take the trade
all the way up to 66 and a half four
points against you you know as you know
that's it's shitty trade to take you
know eventually yeah we did make a new
low we got down here to sixty and a half
so you know assuming assuming right you
could your target is two points at sixty
and a half are you going to risk four
points that when to get two points no of
course not as soon as this thing starts
ticking up here at you know you're short
it to a nap starts hitting three and a
half four you're thinking and you
get covering it you know you're taking
your loss that's why I prefer to get
confirmation of where to get the
breakout rather than everyone sort of
coming in here euphoric thinking hey you
know this pile in and take out the low
and make new lows no you know I want to
make the new lows first but anyway you
know I got point control on the bottom
racial bonds low no divergence you got
that selling and balance there sticks
out quite obvious this was a decent
buying opportunity here and market shot
up you know I said back up to six and a
half Delta scalper gave you a signal
right up here I mean you had a dumb
scalpers by here up here so you got to
buy it in a Cell so a nice little back
and forth there another buy here this
one just goes sideways on you eventually
you come down here you make a new low
again point of control right on the low
okay just like a head here
go to control right on the low you know
when you see that in green bars you know
at lows the days pay attention to them
you know it's a great training
opportunity and with this time the
market rallies back up you know from
sixty and a half all the way up to sixty
four and a half going sideways Delta
scalper by here Delta ska Purcell there
again you know the people think wow this
is not much you know thought depends on
you know type of trader you are this is
a four range chart okay if you're
training on a dome right training on
dome you're looking to get you know
three or four ticks you know you're not
looking to get three or four points if
you got something that could signal to
you a you know short-term supply and
demand has changed you know get long
here or hey you know it's changed get
short here you know get short here you
know you're just looking at some nice
little scalp trades here one two three
right there but then the rest of the day
is kind of worn you just sort of go
sideways you know here's another Delta
scalp or cell coming down into here
which you know in the evening session
that's where we are right now okay so
this is Japanese yen this is the Delta
scalp right it runs on a normal bar
chart as well as a footprint chart I do
think you know it's best used if you
understand order flow rather than just
coming and looking for some shiny object
that you can trade with but again now
I'm just showing you this because I'm
not trying to say yeah you would have
taken this trade right ahead of the
retail number and he would have caught
this trade but you know that trade aside
okay and this is right after you know
again I'm not gonna say you would have
taken this trade and not taking this one
but anyway you know take it after after
eight o'clock you can some nice signals
he okay this one fails make it comes
right back with a nice trade here it's
all blue so you just stay long right so
if you're buying it down here you know I
mean this is what is that ninety forty
four all the way up to sixty s you know
here you get a sell sells off sort of
rallies back up a bit
another sell here another shell there
this one is by fails then you come into
the two o'clock close so again you know
depending on you know what style
the trading you are surely you can get
trades out of the market using this
using the Delta scalper again you know
sometimes you know people I know people
always want to have you know some sort
of holy grail system that's just going
to pick every single turning point right
here's a 987 tick chart in the e-mini s
the s'more nning you sell here comes
back up that's 6:00 in the morning here
this is around nine o'clock here or so
and then a body fails so next will sell
here buy sell a nice little buy here in
this rally now I like looking at like I
had I normally don't look at this Nasdaq
233 tick chart but you know what
somebody bought this thing and it was
just real pain in the ass because he
says y'all you didn't get it quick
enough and you know it doesn't work on
his charts but I tell ya that's why I
keep up these this 233 tick chart
because he says he looks at 233 tick
chart and Nasdaq crude oil and a four
range in the mini Dow and you know I
just want to show you you know when
people say it doesn't work I don't know
what people expect out of an indicator
yes this trade failed but here you're
getting a little bit again I don't know
what time frame I don't know how he's
trading with a scalping for ticks or
he's looking to trade on a 233 tick
chart and hold it for 5 hours who knows
okay who knows but you know just
eyeballing it
you know it's picking nice turning
points you know and I know people that
would just be happy to get you know a
couple moves like this this move this
move you know this move here
you know this move it kept me happy to
get 2 or 3 moves like this a day you
know these these small little wins and
losses will wash each other out and at
the end of the day you'll be breaking
even a lot of these but what you want to
do is you want to catch those those
moves you know here here all right you
get short a 15 covered down it at O 5
yeah you just do that three or four
times you know I don't need you to do it
three or four times a day you do it you
know once or twice a day
and you can make a nice living right you
know catch a move like this so I move Oh
6 down to 98
now you could deal with the small
break-even trades you know this will
take care of themselves I haven't looked
at the other other charts but I mean you
know I try to explain people you know
it's an order flow tool right so it
reads the order flow as it comes in it's
not going to just automatically back
plot everything on there no it needs the
data as it comes in this is the 233 tick
chart let's go back this is what's 6:00
in the morning yeah if he a small winner
a loss small winner small winter small
winner I won't put that up as a loss
it's a nice little winner this one now
okay so people say oh look at this you
know I took this ready to failed the
Chris traders failed well why it okay I
know that people want a trading system a
red light green light trading system but
you know I'll give you a little bit of
information let the market take you in
because you've got a buy signal let the
market start moving in that direction
you know I know a lot of people that use
this they use it this is the entry bar
plus two or three ticks right so if
you're not getting the follow up buying
in the next bar especially on a fast
moving chart like a 233 tick chart let
the market take you in at the market
start going lower and getting short let
the market start going higher if it's
not it put trades probably not going to
work out you know like this right here
okay so here you get short but then the
next two bars are up okay wait you know
give it some chance let it start coming
down before you're getting in all right
let it make a new low you know break
through this low here or break through
the high of this bar here all right like
this one signals on this bar here and
next bar up okay it stopped you out but
you know there's going to be times where
it just doesn't give you that follow up
follow up selling you know but area I
mean it's still giving you some decent
trades so even though you're getting
stopped out on some say just taking
every single signal
you're still getting decent amount of
signals in here you know here here so
take a look at the mini doll for range
chart just to wrap it up in for range
chart and the mini dollars I think
ridiculous to trade off but hey you know
whatever floats your boat
let's go back here so it's 6:00 in the
morning and really 7 o'clock 8 ideally
it should be trading it around 8:30
this is 8:30 here so you could I don't
want to say forget all this but again
you know you're going to get the most
blue quiddity and invest trading
opportunities I think in the mini Dow
and Nasdaq during the cash open so you
get a nice little buy here sell this buy
fails so nice little sell there move
back and forth action here little sell
here so you know mini dollars yeah kind
of mixed Nasdaq performed better today
just see if I got hand interesting
charts to show you today or the end was
so I said hey and look the end looked
really nice let me just
Oh chart - I'm looking for my soybean
chart I haven't looked at soybeans
honestly today I looked at it early in
the session but I haven't five I'm
looking back at him since so it's about
9:00 this morning
of course if I could just find my chart
here
well anyway let's take a look at buns
real quick and once what is it
interesting this morning so anyway I go
back here when he got you know off the
high you got the delta scalp or given a
cell is by here this one didn't work out
came coming down into these lows failed
ratio and divergence the delta scalper
then I sell there there's another point
control around the bottom next bar up up
two bars this is nice Delta scalper buy
both of these they're on the same level
so I'm not surprising to see the buying
come back in now the first one you know
may be able to stop the off second one
definitely you could have caught a ride
don't discover a little bit of a sell
here didn't work out here's a delta
scalper sell this bars interesting
porter control right on the top and then
you sold off until the close here's the
soybeans again and si haven't looked at
it I'm just curious see if there's
anything interesting not really coming
down into these lows here you got this
one
I find this bar bullish bullish but no
follow-through the next bar came down
here made made a new little make new
lows here this one doesn't have a ratio
this one does have a ratio this is a
Delco surge but yeah I mean we sold off
but again you're not you know any buying
opportunities you had this one here that
failed honestly but it's just kind of
bearish overall said you got the Delta
surge here so you know the deltas it's
picking up in the negative sense you
know coming down into these lows that
you know maybe there's a potential of
what's going lower which obviously we
did so I'm not a great chart show you
but again still I want to show you again
you know not every time does order full
pick every single turning point now
sometimes there's just nothing in the
flow the markets just facilitating trade
the way it should do but you know again
I just want to show you how it looks
okay so anyway I'm you know thanks for
watching this and to learn more about
order flow visit website order flows
comm subscribe to our YouTube channel
and if you're interested in Delta
scalper go to Delta scalper calm
thanks everyone bye-bye